can people find a mechanic that they can  trust because when people go to get oil  changes a lot of the times you go for  the oil and they say oh this is broken  this is broken this is broken apparently  you need to fix ASAP on your car yeah  when you say when you say well is my car  going to break if I don't fix this stuff  they always go you know so I like to  believe that most people are going to be  good people and does it need to be  changed right there if you could yeah if  it's hard to afford it not necessarily  that's why it's important to find  somebody that you could trust somebody  that has great reviews from your friends  and family I mean the reason why I made  my channel was because you don't know  those things you don't know how to fix  your own car you have to rely on  somebody else and Automotive has a bad  rep for you never know getting taken  advantage